make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level series
we're gonna be covering Swamp Thing now
Swamp Thing was created by Lin wine and
Bernie Wrightson and made his debut in a
house of secrets number 92 in 1971 Swamp
Thing his origin has undergone some
retconning since his initial release but
the one thing that's widely accepted
sinners on alec holland a biologist that
was working on a formula that he
believes would eliminate food shortages
throughout the world through the
restoration of plant life now some
criminals broke into Holland's lab
knocked him unconscious and left a bomb
that explodes when he wakes at cover
with his formula and on fire pollen ran
into Louisiana swampland which reacted
with the local plant life to create a
hybrid of plant and human that would
become the Swamp Thing now what we later
learned is that Alec Holland is merely
the most recent in a series of avatars
of the green a dimension that's the life
force of all plant life on earth now as
the Greens Avatar Swamp Thing is charged
with protecting it from any threats
especially the Roth the force the powers
death and decay and the gray which is
the elemental source of fungus and is
attempted to overthrow the Parliament of
trees the group of former avatars of the
green that rule over its respective
realm now as an avatar of the Green
Swamp Thing possesses a variety of
different powers most of which are
centered around his connection with
plant life Swamp Thing possesses
superhuman strength and has quite a few
feats that place him among the elite
tier of DC characters in terms of pure
strength
for example he was able to restrain
Superman render Etrigan the demon
unconscious with one punch
rip another demon known as The Monkey
King to shreds incapacitate Captain Atom
and troll Batman that's actually true
like a lot of you guys know that if
there's like I literally have a video
called Swamp Thing trolls Batman it's
this hilarious thing Swamp Thing gets
Batman if I remember correctly Swamp
Thing gets Batman to help him out by
basically saying that like nothing ever
truly dies it just goes to the green
like it returns to the gray returns to
the earth and so he's like if you helped
like if you help me I could help you
find a way to restore your parents and
so like swamp like that man helps Swamp
Thing he's like okay cool so he helps
Swamp Thing and so the two of them go on
their mission together and at the end of
it all
Batman's like said what about my parents
the Swamp things like nah man they're
dead but there's no way to bring him
back I'm like what about life
everlasting
[Laughter]
of the swampthing controlled Batman I
thought it was absolutely hysterical but
any event swampthing also exhibits a
high level of durability he's unfazed by
bullets has survived blows from some of
DC strongest characters including
Superman and Wonder Woman and has also
survived being hit with Superman's heat
vision the swampthing also has a highly
effective regenerative healing factor
that allows him to heal even from
extreme injuries and death rendering him
effectively immortal he can regrow limbs
and has even regrown his entire body in
less than a minute after being destroyed
now during crisis on Infinite Earths
when the anti mater practically
destroyed reality Swamp Thing was able
to send his consciousness to a different
universe and regrow his body meaning
that he is not even limited by the
boundaries of the physical universe that
he exists in his most distinctive power
is as clora Kinesis or the ability to
control all plant life now when I say he
could control plant life I mean he can
basically do anything he wants he can
cause plants to grow how they transform
Gotham City into a jungle regenerate
dead plants increase his own size to
larger than an island or decrease it
down to a microscopic level create
structures out of plants give himself
wings basically anything he can think of
that can be done by using plant matter
he can basically do it on one occasion
Swamp Thing even manipulated the
microscopic plant cells within John
Constantine's gun to cause him enough
pain to temporarily incapacitate him and
remarked that he could have killed him
if he wanted on a separate occasion he
performed a similar feat and actually
turned someone into a tree as a result
which means he's able to manipulate
matter on a cellular level and let's
just think about that for a second Swamp
Thing turned a person into a tree right
like it's every hippies dream to become
a tree right nor that reminds me of it
reminds me of that video with with Don
Cheadle when he plays Captain Planet and
like if you guys haven't seen it it's
hilarious like Don Cheadle plays yet the
Don Cheadle is a guy who played played
war machine and basically all the movies
except for Iron Man one he plays Captain
Planet and it just starts like losing
his mind and he turns everybody in the
world into trees but it's hilarious he's
like tree tree tree tree tree tree tree
tree but it's it's some dude it's
amazing he's like I did it they're all
trees he turned every human being on
earth into trees but regardless due to
his connection to the green swamp thing
is also able to enter the astral plane
and his projected his consciousness to
other planets he can also send others
into the ash
realm as he did when he separated
Constantine from his body and sent his
essence into the astral plane itself
he's also shown an immunity to telepathy
as a telepathic attack from Aquaman
proved to be completely ineffectual
against Swamp Thing which kind of makes
sense because Aquaman talks to fish not
trees he can also affect the psyches of
others by releasing and controlling the
natural hallucinogens and plants to
cause others to hallucinate he can also
speed up his metabolic rate using his
control of microorganisms to secrete an
acid strong enough to dissolve stone see
this is why this one thing is so
underrated people who are kind of book
fans will be like dude Swamp Thing is
legit but like if you're not a comic
book fan like if you're not really
reading comics you don't really read
Swamp Thing you're like Swamp Thing
there's a giant green ugly looking guy
who comes from the swamp right like it's
a dude covered in algae how powerful can
you really be who this guy is Opie man
this is nuts like see I wanna see
Swamp Thing goin on like a murderous
frenzy right like I'm gonna see him
going I'm allergic just like run up on
people and just like spew acid all over
me like I look like The Swamp Thing TV
show I think did it
and see here's the shame about it you
did we are we are digressing so bad in
this video here's a shame about it too
the season of Swamp Thing was amazing
dude I have no idea was gonna be that
good also okay so Swamp Thing like a guy
with a bag covered in algae you lives in
a swamp
whatever man he's like the old man of
the woods except he's all about plants
and stuff dude that show was on amazing
and I'm so disappointed that they
cancelled it and that we're not gonna
get a season to you right ladies so
disappointing that we're not gonna get a
season two because I thought it was I
thought was awesome
I'm really hoping somebody else picks it
up right somebody goes to one of others
and it's like hey so like since you're
not gonna give the people what would be
what they want we will like I don't know
why they canceled in the first place
they started something about taxes or
something along those lines I have no
idea I think it's a bunch of malarkey I
think they canceled it because I didn't
think it was gonna be popular or maybe
it was too expensive to make I don't
know but uh they need to make more do
because Swamp Thing wasn't an amazing
show here's here's my question for you
guys alright here's my question because
Mariah asked this question when we were
both enjoying herbs you guys picking up
what I'm putting down and there's this
question she asked Swamp Thing versus
grandmother willow from Pocahontas
that's what I want to see I'm gonna see
that fight I wanna see grandmother
willow from Pocahontas fighting Swamp
Thing that would be amazing
that would be hilarious but with all
this in mind Swamp Thing is essentially
well
yawn omega-level not only is he
effectively immortal as long as there's
even one spore of plant life left on
earth for him to regrow from but he's
able to control all the plant life on
earth meaning that he's definitely a
planetary level threat also it bears
knowing that we probably haven't seen
the upper limit of Swamp things
capabilities as the Green is able to
funnel extra power to him should the
need arise so his power level can
continue to increase to fit the
situation then he finds himself in and
so although Swamp Thing isn't a name
that typically gets brought up when
discussing the most powerful characters
in DC Comics it definitely should be
this guy is crazy Opie so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end let me know you guys
think here's here's another cool thing -
all right here's a little cool thing -
because this little bit is for people
who waited until the end of the video if
you didn't wait to the end of the video
then you're not you're not gonna know
about this but I am selling Rob four
rings go to Instagram calm slash I am
Rob Jefferson to get to get the to get
the details there we go I cannot talk
anyway instagram.com slash I am Rob
Jefferson I am selling Rob four rings
there and yes it's it's cool I will let
you know when they are available and
they'll probably be available in the
next day or two but with that being said
guys we're gonna read this video to an
end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob 4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I'll catch you
all later peace
[Music]